Good morning John it is Tuesday.
Nope, Friday. Good morning Hank! It's a reunion videooooooo...
Hi
How are you?
How are.... we're...
Ooooooooooooooooo
Hank: We both kind of look tan
John: No I think it's cause of the bad lighting.
So a very special question tuesday John.
It's been nine years that we've been making vlogbrothers videos
I wanted to do a question tuesday in which we tell people things
that they still don't know about us.
I asked Twitter and here are some of the questions that I received
Who had more girlfriends in elementary through highschool?
John: Hmmmm me!
Hank: Yes I had more girlfriends in elementary school though I will say.
John: Hmm I killed it in elementary school.
Hank: No you didn't!
John: I had long term relationships in elementary school.
Hank: That's right I was just like hop hop hop hop hop
I held so many hands.
John: Did you?
John: When you were kids did you know what you wanted to be when you grew up?
Hank: I thought that I wanted to be an oceanographer.
But it turns out that I don't like boats.
John: I did want to be a writer when I was a kid but I never thought that it was a realistic job
I thought it was like wanting to be an astronaut or something.
What is the pettiest thing that you still argue about?
We did have an argument yesterday about which part of the human body would take the longest to eat.
John: No I feel like the argument was about which part of the human body would make the largest contiguous steak.
It's all petty until you're a cannibal. And than it's suddenly very very real.
Hank: Gwen asks "Does John cast movies?"
John: No
Hank: "Who has bigger ears?" asks Sarah.
John: Hmm I don't know my ears are this big.
Hank: My ears are this big.
Hank: Let's measure with the Goonies.
Like right here
John: Okay
Hank: I made a little mark.
John: Alright. Then I'll go. I have the bigger ears.
[Hank laughs]
But I'm older!
Hank: Yeah they keep growing
John: They keep getting bigger.
Henry is right behind the camera and uh I just asked him if the video was funny
and he said no so I'm concerned so Hank can you do something funny?
[Hank makes fart sounds]
[All laugh]
John: He laughed!
[Hank makes more fart noises]
[Henry laughs]
John: Alright the video is funny again.
Hank: Bubble baths. Soothing relaxation
John: Yes
Hank: or boiling cesspool
John: Ohhh
Hank: Boiling cesspool.
John: Nooo Nooo Nooo Noo! We're about to have the pettiest argument we've ever had.
[Hank laughs]
John: Baths are wonderful!
Hank: It feels like putting my entire body on every other part of my body.
Ainsley asks: Nerdfighter emoji?
There are, there is one that I use
John: Is it this one?
Hank: Yes the lady who is going like this.
John: Hank what is your 20 year goal?
Hank: Ooohh when I'm 55...I wanna still have a colon.
[John laughs]
John: How is Dave Green?
Hank: Fine. He's doing good.
John: Whenever I'm like "How are you doing?" he's just like
Hank: Living the dream!
John: L T D !
Hank: He does say that it's weird.
John: I don't think it's that weird I think it's cool.
Hank: I keep thinking it's FTD which is the flower delivery service.
Have you ever seen each other poop?
John: Hahahahaha Henry is finally laughing again.
Probably when yeah..Hank was like three months old but it's been a while.
Hank: Rapid fire. What's your favourite musical?
John: Hamilton.
Hank: What's your favourite poem?
John: The second coming by W. B. Yeats.
Hank: What book have you reread more than any other?
John: Puhhh actually probaby Hatchet by Gary Paulsen if you go back to my childhood.
John: Last question Hank. What do you think of as your biggest accomplishment?
When you do that it makes shadow animals on my body.
[Hank makes duck noises]
John: Is this your biggest accomplishment right now? This? Making a terrible duck
that kisses me on the cheek?
My biggest professional accomplishment is vlogbrothers. Uhm my biggest personal
personal accomplishment is uhm behind the camera.
Hank: You picked Henry?!
John: No I mean.. but I...
Hank: I also am really proud of vlogbrothers, of course.
But among that in there I think my greatest accomplishment is having made the internet's
most viewed video of a goat giving birth.
It's a thing that I did
John: It's incredible
Hank: No one can take that away from me.
John: I'll see you on friday.
Tuesday.
I'm so bad at days.
Hank: Yeah I know.
I know. It's gonna be a problem for our whole lives.